what's he thawing it's squishy i'm gonna
put this on this
thing oh wow
[Music]
hey guys it's inka as most of you know i
do a lot of these one color food cooking
challenges
one of my friends who loves the color
pink is going to try and recreate my
pink color food challenge for 24 hours
super excited and i can't wait to see
what he comes up with
hi sean hi inga how are you i'm excited
because you're going to be trying my one
color food challenge and you're going to
be doing pink foods do you kind of have
like a plan
going into this no if you have any
advice or tips please let me know
you want to find naturally colored pink
foods which is an adventure in itself
and i think you'll have
a lot of fun with it you know especially
because you love pink that's like the
most important thing to keep in mind and
then really just let your
creative genius take over bring it on
i am going to just look for as much pink
foods as possible pink foods are
naturally colored
now that i'm thinking about it it is a
lot harder than i thought if i was a
pink ingredient where am i gonna be at
i see these kroger pink beans do not
know
beans were pink salmon ooh pink
himalayan salt
i got this i'm feeling it in my bones
the pink energy is
flowing through me oh what's this this
looks good i'm gonna add this
i'm gonna add this okay so i got some
strawberry yogurt
add add to cart adding spam to the cart
we have shrimp this is very pink
strawberry applesauce as a cart
i'm gonna press pay and we'll see what
happens i'm
super duper excited is officially the
start of my 24 hour
pink challenge i'm all pinked out look
at this
for breakfast i wanted to keep it very
simple just because
inga and her video kept it really simple
so i wanted to pay homage to that
first i have all natural guava juice
it's guava nectar
it reminds me of home in hawaii the next
thing i have is freeze-dried
strawberries this is what the raspberry
yogurt looks like it's a very soft
like dusty rose so i'm gonna just add
these freeze dried strawberries just to
give a little texture a little munch
munch crunch crunch
for actual meat i have ham over here the
turkey is a light pink
and finally i have these pink beans so i
finally made my breakfast
i paid homage to you are you ready for
it are you ready for the room ready i'm
ready i'm so excited show me shut up
nice i'm very impressed like i'm excited
now to see what you're gonna do for
lunch
just hearing those words that you given
your pink seal of approval made me so
happy and i can't wait for lunch and
dinner i'll
sign off now so you can enjoy your pink
breakfast
definitely adding the strawberries to
give it more of a texture
and a hint of sweetness was just like
chef's kiss they're different shades of
pink definitely a good snack
this is my favorite ever i love guava
juice oh that's good
that's good overall super simple
breakfast and a super super super
pink breakfast i want to go to my asian
supermarket and find some really cool
asian pink items let's head out first
thing i found is right over here
it's this radish i got myself some
pickled ginger
there's these japanese pickles there's
this plum this
is plum salmon so sumet is a type of
noodle this is ume flavor or plum
flavored
oh look what i got over here so if you
check the side the ice cream is made
from natural strawberries so that's how
it's pink coloring
and also the actual mochi itself it's
from uh beet juice
so i'm outside now at this really cool
cafe this cafe
has a naturally pink rose latte so
aesthetic it's so pleasing i saw the
pictures on the website and i was like i
have to go
so good the flavoring of the coffee is
just
on point so i went to a japanese
supermarket so i do have a quick
question though so obviously i have the
salmon and the spam
and like this looks like a very much
japanese asian dish
however what do i do with all of these
most of these look like cold side dishes
normally maybe you could just plate it
up in a way that you know like it's a
side dish it's like a garnish to
i'm assuming what is going to be your
main the noodle dish
you're smart you're brilliant you're
stunning okay
top chef okay master chef i see you i
just want to say
i'm very impressed by the fact that you
are able to source these things
very very excited to see what you're
going to put together so for those who
don't know i'm from hawaii
i'm gonna do an homage to my japanese
and hawaiian heritage
i have my japanese plum noodles and
hawaiians
love japanese food and hawaiians love
spam so obviously i have to get spam so
we're gonna grill this
really quickly get a nice light sear
on it i have all these assorted
vegetables and according to inga she
told me to cut it up and make a cute
little like pickled salad
and serve it as it is guess what i used
the plum juice
and i made this super pretty pink rice
look at that
so let's start plating these colors are
stunning and i can't wait to try it
and here is my pink launch definitely
first thing i want to try
are these pink summer noodles there's a
slight ume or plum flavor to it so it's
a little bit sour i'm gonna eat pink
noodles more often now
next i have spam with the vegetables all
over it
this is a work of art i am picasso i'm
sean castle
it's heavily ume flavored it tastes so
good
overall i thought lunch was a huge
success
i like the way he plated it together he
was worried for no reason and i kind of
want like a snacky snack because your
boy is still hungry but i don't want to
eat dinner just yet
so i have a couple of snacks pink snacks
this first item is
a strawberry applesauce i have these
rice cakes these are
strawberry yogurt rice cakes whoa this
is
this is like almost like the size of
like my face
a little salty but also like really
sweet itadakimasu
i took all the other pink ingredients i
have i don't exactly know
what to make but i'm hoping that the
pink
gods will send me some pink energy and
make this possible
i know for salmon you need to grill it
so i'm gonna grill my pink salmon
fun fact i actually don't eat fish and i
don't really know how to cook fish wish
me luck
what's your thought it's squishy i'm
gonna put this on this thing
ah oh wow this is how i'm supposed to be
doing it
so my fish is grilling right now to
maybe help it out i have some pink
himalayan salt
i don't know how to salt i'm trying to
do the salt thinking majigger
there's a ceiling cap hey sean checking
in to see how you're doing
i still haven't figured out what to do
yet i grilled
fish for the first time and i'm just
cutting some radishes
sounds like you have things pretty under
control something i always do is like to
make sure i have my protein my
vegetables
sounds like you hit all of those i think
no matter how
you make this meal it's going to be
great i'm just nervous i wanted to go
off with a bang y'alls
i'm gonna let you go back to cutting
your radishes i don't want you to
cut and talk to me at the same time so
you don't end up
getting into an accident all right you
can do this let's
keep on cooking now i'm gonna cut my red
potatoes
put it in a pot hopefully i can get a
really pink
and for the rhubarb i got frozen rhubarb
so this is what it looks like i'm gonna
put this in the microwave for about 30
seconds or a minute so i
added the rhubarb with the red potatoes
and now it looks like a
really pink mashed potato my salmon is
done my prosciutto and my shrimp is
already cooked so finally it's time to
plate
so this is my dinner yeah so it didn't
quite turn out like i imagined
but it's pink so we have these mashed
potatoes that combines with rhubarb
so it's a very pale skin pink and i also
have the prosciutto which is the
variation of pink
i have this salmon and shrimp that i
covered in a beautiful dragon fruit
glaze
so it's like a fuchsia pink i'm going to
call it
50 shades of pink now we're going to try
these mashed potato rhubarbs i don't
want to try it
oh it's not that bad i'm going to try
the prosciutto i'm going to just rip
this off
we're sure so good finally i'm going to
try the dragon fruit shrimp and the
dragon fruit
salmon real talk i'm actually surprised
cause like i don't like fish but the
dragon fruit glaze definitely
hid the fishiness from the salmon so
it's almost like a little bit of a salty
sweet moment
i am very proud of myself right now i
think dinner was definitely the hardest
one
because i didn't know what to do and i
had a bunch of random ingredients around
and it just goes to show how great inga
is this is
way harder than she made it look i think
she'd be so proud of the effort i put
into this and that i did my best
the day is done and i get to finish it
off with dessert
bam tada i don't know what happened
i might have possibly left it out a
little too long and melted in the car so
we're gonna have some
mochi ice cream
cheers it's still good no hate it's so
amazing i'm still gonna eat it all
so overall i thought this was a really
difficult but really fun challenge
it's really hard to find a full balanced
meal that's only naturally pink
overall this was a great experience and
i would definitely urge everyone else to
try this challenge with your favorite
color
inga thank you so much for letting me do
this i'm gonna just finish my mochi
so see y'all later
you